we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P we haven't heard from
him for a while
But Eric from Mass Eric from
Massachusetts uh who has been insisting
for years I'm about to get sued I'm
about to get arrested I'm about to get
imprisoned because I quote promoted the
vaccines by which he means I reported
the scientific information about them he
now it it's really going to happen now
I'm really about to get arrested now
hey David a federal for Mass get ready
uh the Bronson case from the Supreme
Court is about to come through and um
all your buddies uh your government
um ones you nominal and every day are
going to be all uh replaced and fired
and probably arrested
um what they did was illegal
and what did they what did they and I do
you're on record saying you want to go
by the Constitution and well you
probably you know all this you just hide
it for me up um people because the
Democrat Party is burning down just like
uh authoritarianism Republicans
authoritarian a scientist is
authoritarian when he let people go to
work uh not wear masks not have to get
vaccinated yeah this guy is obsessed huh
man you have a backwards back without
work on life
you've destroyed people's lives
Democrats destroyed the country I'm not
even a Democrat and I had no no
influence whatsoever on policy so I
don't know how I destroyed anyone's life
he destroyed people's lives
all over a common cold
I mean
you know you talk about critical
thinking how can you possibly critically
think that some guy on TV tells you to
get a shot you'll hope you're I'll go
get all the food stuff oh you can get
either of the dirt or a fight or a mix
of the bathroom you get mix and match
drums
someone on the TV said you could
so Eric from Mass still fully on and
very very dangerous stuff going on over
there but I am standing by for when they
take me away in handcuffs uh let's see
if and when it happens I'm sure it will
be much to Eric's Delight if it does
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about this new low
confidence report from the Department of
energy
about the oranges of covid we will talk
about the NPR layoffs and what is going
on in media with the layoffs and we will
give you the latest on Senator John
Federman and his path to recovery all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
get the bonus show folks get the bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code please no more Trump
that's the code all one word no spaces
please no more Trump it'll save you a
bundle and then we'll see you on the
bonus show